Edie I've heard you say previously that
the wounds of men make them who they are
how would you say that bobby fischer's
wounds made him for better or worse well
I think that his gift was also his curse
I think the fact that he chose chess or
that it shows him led him on a path that
inevitably led to his demise I think
that that that the nature of chess in
its obsessions and it's kind of
alienation and isolation fed right into
what must have been something already
you know congenital in his brain and
that coupled with his background were
the seeds of of tragedy on the other
hand without them he never could have
triumphed in the way that he did and and
he did triumph and so I guess that that
he is defined by his struggle I think I
also heard you say that you believe not
only an actor should go through a
character's process and struggle but
also a writer director should as well
did you go into any of those places in
your own mind for bobby fisher' and his
life and I think that I think if there's
truly an intimate relationship between
an actor and a director it is shared I
think the director has to go there to
some degree some of it may be
articulated and some of it not as you
try to visualize a scene as you try to
think of how to portray an experience
that's delusional or paranoid or or or
you know emotional in any way I think
you have to go there and and I think
that your willingness to go there is
also means that that actors not going
there alone how do you get the best
performance from an actor
I think it's I mean mostly it's about
trust but it's also about the creation
of a universe in which there can be
nothing but truth that's to say the
staging the costumes the lighting the
set everything has to have a default of
authenticity so that when that actor is
in that world he can only be rather than
try to present or portray he can just
exist in that space and let things
happen spontaneously and I think that is
probably the the simplest way to put it
leaving a character in a precarious
situation or I think you've said before
you like it when your characters are
able to walk off into the sunset and
everything's wonderful but so much of
life is not that way and we see with
Bobby Fischer yeah that's it you know it
doesn't always happen that way does it
you know I mean I think you see
absolutely in his moment of triumph
everything that's to follow is written
and and and what happens after that is
is inevitable in that sense it makes it
a tragedy thank you so much